From casting and direction, to props and wardrobe,
every little piece involved in a major motion
picture becomes gilded in history until the
end of time.
But although the hours of footage passes by
a thousand professionally-trained eyes, sometimes
a wardrobe malfunction skips all of the censors
lands in the final cut.
Whether no one noticed, or the picture was
already locked, these blockbusters hit the
big screen with wardrobe pieces that were
way out of place.
Too bold for the background
Steven Spielberg's Raiders of the Lost Ark
keenly depicts Egypt in the mid-1930s.
"Who knows, in a thousand years, maybe even
you will be worth something."
"Ha ha ha ha"
But between the earth-toned trinkets and the
intricate tapestries that line the city markets,
one guy totally blows the magic of cinema.
Just behind Harrison Ford's Indiana Jones,
you'll spot a guy wearing blue jeans and a
T-shirt, casually passing by.
A misplaced crew member, or a time-traveling
adventurer?
You decide.
Undies from the future
Russell Crowe takes the lead in Ridley Scott's
Gladiator as a general bent on vengeance following
the murder of his family.
"My name is Maximus Decimus Meridius, Commander
of the Armies of the North, General of the
Felix legions, and loyal servant to the true
emperor Marcus Aurelius."
But what ripped some viewers out of the moment,
however, was the wardrobe malfunction in the
middle of a fight scene — where Crowe's
Lycra shorts made a guest appearance from
under his tunic.
Which, we suppose, is better than nothing.
What time (period) is it?
Starring industry heavyweights, and helmed
by Academy Award-winning filmmaker Edward,
Glory earned well-deserved accolades when
it debuted in 1989.
"If tomorrow we have to meet our Judgment
Day, our Heavenly Father, we want you to let
our folks know… uh, that we died facing
the enemy!"
Critics lauded the American Civil War-set
film for its breathtaking cinematography,
and "enormous attention to period detail"
— praise which comes off as a bit ironic
today, considering the wardrobe piece that
made it to the theatrical cut.
We're pretty sure that digital time-telling
technology wouldn't have been around in 19th-century
America.
But that wasn't the only time a timepiece
stole the scene.
A Rolex out of time
Bear with us, because this one is really nerdy.
With its pitch-perfect soundtrack, superb
costume design, and fine-tuned set design,
David O. Russell's American Hustle provides
an excellent snapshot of the sights and sounds
of the '70s.
The main cast seems to have walked straight
out of the disco-crazed decade, and so does
supporting actor Louis C.K. — except for
one detail.
The Rolex C.K.'s character wears may look
super fancy, but it isn't era-appropriate.
It's a GMT-Master II Rolex with a ceramic
bezel — first made around 2010.
"Y'know we'll finish the ice story another
time young man."
The erroneous earpiece
Captain America: The First Avenger launched
star Chris Evans further into superstardom
and stands as one of the most well-loved Marvel
movies in history.
"How do you feel?"
"Taller."
But in the midst of all the "pulpy action"
and "pleasantly retro vibe" that the critics
applauded, there's an historical slip-up that
surprisingly made it into the film.
Right before Cap and his crew raid a HYDRA
train, Kenneth Choi's character is shown wearing
an unusually high-tech earpiece — which
definitely didn't exist during WWII.
A little too much skin
Even if you've never seen Closer, you've certainly
seen Natalie Portman's character, the dancer
from America who arrives in London, and falls
for Jude Law's character.
"Would you like me to stop being cheeky."
In the final cut, she only flaunts a little
skin.
But thanks to a wardrobe malfunction, a lot
more is shown.
While talking to Clive Owen, Portman's top
slips into "N-S-F-W" territory.
Needless to say, it ended up in the movie
anyway.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!